[Music]
when you're shopping for a new car
safety should be your top priority you
can always look at the safety features
of the vehicle you're about to buy but
the safety ratings make the process of
decision making quicker
and it seems one company is leading in
safety ratings around the globe we're
talking of course about
tesla tesla has consistently received
five star ratings from companies that
conduct crash tests but how does it work
so efficiently
every time that's what we're going to
find out today welcome back to our
channel
if you haven't already make sure you hit
that subscribe button and ring the bell
so you're notified every time we upload
a new video
tesla has been acing every test put
forward by the national highway traffic
safety administration for years
and their most recent test was in
january 2021
the tesla model y cleared it with flying
colors
and received a five-star rating but what
goes into determining a car's level of
safety
how is it measured before we dive into
the specifics of what makes tesla so
safe let's look at some essential safety
features we need to keep in mind when
buying a car
airbags brakes electronic stability
control
adaptive headlights and traction control
when insurance companies and road safety
regulators test cars
they typically have six main categories
they test three of them include three
different kinds of
front end impacts whiplash side impacts
and roof strength in case the car
topples over
the aim is to ensure the car protects
adults and children
see how it treats vulnerable road users
like pedestrians and check the safety
assists
and as tesla fans already know tesla
vehicles
are just about the safest on the planet
the model 3 has the lowest probability
of injury in a collision of any of the
plus vehicles tested by the nhtsa sounds
incredible doesn't it how does a company
as young as tesla
build more efficient and safer cars than
what legacy car makers have been
building for decades
tesla's underlying architecture and
design goes a long way
in making the car rigid and safe the car
has no
engine just a battery since it's an
electric car all that steel
and aluminum in the front absorbs a
majority of the impact
so it doesn't transfer to the passengers
sitting inside and because it's an
electric car
there's no gas tank either so teslas
have larger front and back crumple
zones than any other vehicle with an
engine in the front and a gas tank in
the rear
elon musk emphasizes the crumple zones
he points out that this
even makes it safer for the car's tesla
hits the combined crumple zone of both
cars
is much longer than if two regular cars
collided
technically it's safer for pedestrians
too because they would simply bounce off
the hood
instead of slamming on an engine block
the location of the battery
also gives the car a low center of
gravity which improves handling
and reduces the chance of a rollover the
model y for example
houses the heavy battery pack and
electric motor in the bottom of the car
it weighs just over a thousand pounds
this makes it the heaviest part of the
car
the motors sit between the wheels giving
an additional
200 pounds between the hubs plus you
have the weight of the tires
for that reason the nhtsa determined the
risk of rollover
at just 6 the only car lower than that
is the tesla model s with a 5.7 percent
chance
speaking of the battery tesla has made
it their top priority when a battery
malm functions the overheating of one
cell
can quickly transfer to the others and
it's called thermal runway but this
doesn't happen in teslas the connections
between
cells are designed to melt at a much
lower temperature than usual
so the circuit essentially breaks and
keeps the other cells safe the cells are
also separated by cooling veins
and each cell has emergency vents that
allow hot gases to escape before they
can build up
enough pressure to cause an explosion
but even with the heavy battery if the
car still manages to roll over
tesla cars have a strong roof that
protects the occupants
most legacy cars use the thinnest and
least rigid bit of sheet metal for the
roof and in a rollover accident
you risk serious injury but tesla cars
have glass roofs which
one might argue is less safe than metal
but you'd be surprised
the roof panels are essentially like
windshields two layers of hardened glass
laminated with thermoplastic the model 3
in particular
has been able to withstand 20 000 pounds
of force on its roof
which is six times its own weight in a
crash test the glass panels break in a
predictable way but the plastic holds
the pieces together so they don't rain
down like jagged shards and hurt the
passengers
the signs are usually the weakest point
of a car since there is nothing to
absorb the impact of a crash but they
have a solution for that
too teslas are reinforced with ultra
high grade steel
and in the event of a side collision a
thick curtain airbag pops out for an
added safety measure
these measures are referred to as
passive safety measures it focuses on
things like airbags
seats and the structure of the car these
elements in tesla contribute to their
high safety rating too
the model 3 has a thick curtain airbag
and a uniquely shaped front passenger
airbag
that help protect the passenger's head
from the car's pillar and center screen
and while
passive safety covers what happens in an
accident active safety refers to the
systems that help a car
avoid a collision in the first place
which brings us to stability control
it is unsurprisingly one of the best on
the road
weight sensors in the seats warn the
driver when the belts aren't safely
buckled in
and determines how powerfully the
airbags should be deployed in the event
of a collision
but in addition to keeping you safe in
an accident it also has
features that prevent accidents from
happening in the first place
the lane departure avoidance feature for
example detects when the car is drifting
into another lane
and steers itself back in this emergency
lane keeping test
you can see how the vehicle crosses over
the white line towards an oncoming
vehicle
and is pulled back into the lane
automatic the automatic emergency
braking system
recognizes obstacles on the roads and
stops by itself
they even improve their aeb system for
all model
s x and 3 vehicles built since october
and they did it using an over-the-air
software update
tesla's engineers actually monitor the
data collected from the sensor suites of
cars to understand driver behavior and
they make their upgrades accordingly
this constant monitoring gives you a
better driving experience and keeps you
safer the newer models also have a
feature called red light recognition
the auto braking feature is by no means
brand new volvo came up with it over a
decade ago but tesla
of course perfected it with their
combination of cameras
radar and ultrasonic sensors autonomous
cars are the next big thing for tesla
and in fact for many other legacy car
makers
none of them have perfected it yet but
select customers have gotten the
opportunity to beta test autonomous
vehicles for tesla
it seems they work by themselves in both
cities and highways
with ease as great as that sounds
drivers still
have to pay attention and be ready to
step in at any time right now we're
still navigating conditional automation
with the cruise control feature
just one level below full self driving
so if their cars are so safe and of
course better for the environment
why aren't they more popular well the
cheapest model 3
is still twice the cost of the least
expensive sedan they also take a very
long time to charge
since their batteries are larger than
what you'll find in any other car
if you like taking long drives or like
backpacking
maybe teslas aren't for you but the
benefits definitely outweigh the costs
it's a fantastic
long-term investment in the environment
and your safety do you think you'll buy
a tesla anytime soon
let us know in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video
make sure you hit the like button and
check out more videos over on the simply
tech
channel thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time
you